you want to talk about the crime wave in
l.a thank god yeah yeah thank god
finally we got to it thank the lord yeah
what is happening
apparently it just crime is up in l.a
why time is up in l.a mark
why is crime so up dude
why is crime so up dude no one really
knows but some people are saying that
gaston is that his name gaston calm guys
going you're talking about the [ __ ]
bad guy i'm beating the beast yeah he's
about to have been gaston so they're
saying that gaston is uh george gascon
is trying to let all the people out swim
it
but what is he exactly saying because i
don't understand
basically the people are getting
released from prison with they're just
robbing places yeah yeah and what is
gaston doing he's telling them to do
that is he like be my guest
[Laughter]
like what is his what is his exact
philosophy
i haven't asked him i don't know
there's not a public word on that and
why are people robbing so much in los
angeles
because there's not being prosecuted as
harsh the crime wave please talk about
the crime wave okay so people are saying
it's like liberal policies that are
making the crime skyrocketing yeah yeah
21 and a half percent had increased yeah
houston crime has increased 30 can i ask
you a question yeah from what year to
what year last year to this year well
last year of course nobody was outside
how are you going to commit crimes if
you're not outside no yeah
that's a good aspect new york violent
crime i'm talking about violent crime
only violent crime is down 46 in new
york last year to this year so it's down
down in new york
so they're saying it's these liberal
cities new york is down la is up but not
as much as houston where it's [ __ ]
have your own gun you don't even need a
permit just buy one and shoot whoever
the [ __ ] you want to crime is up more
so maybe conservatives can stop being
such [ __ ] oh shy babies about a
little bit of crime seth rogen is kind
of right
oh [ __ ] hey it's carl living in this big
city you cux
all right you [ __ ] cucks country
mouse you won't call
williamsburg all right but 2019 to 2021
la
homicides up 47 percent that is [ __ ]
shooting victims up 51 big deal weirdly
like the robberies and everything that
people are talking about statistically
not super increased but it's super
visible all of the
flash robberies and it's happening from
again another reform is uh elimination
of cash bail these guys get in get out
yeah
but the other thing i was wondering if
it's like um
i wonder if it the narrative gets set
and then when you see anybody rob
anything it just makes the news yeah but
now it justifies our fear yeah right so
the narrative is set
and the narrative is right now in la
people are robbing now it's not like
people just started robbing in l.a yeah
people have been robbing in l.a yeah
the most famous gangs ever started in
l.a
right what were they doing before 2021
i don't know good samaritans i guess
exactly
they continue that [ __ ] the marathon
yeah you're right continues
people are going to take that in
different ways for different people you
know what i mean
you know what i'm saying like different
people taking different ways if you're
the race you're running is busting open
louis vuitton and snatching purses and
[ __ ]
that marathon continues bro you're right
you know what i'm saying so i would say
to dove i bet if you look across any
city
2019-21 crime is way the [ __ ] up in any
big city yeah because it's just that's
what happened we all had the [ __ ]
pandemic we all got let out we've been
inside for nine months people with
mental illness didn't [ __ ] interact
with anybody you didn't get to be normal
i bet crime way up everywhere stop being
a little [ __ ] about it whoa
living in a big city yo holy [ __ ] right
now holy [ __ ] right now
i'm i'm just saying i like what's
happening though you know why oh why
are you going down all this [ __ ] goes
public the hammer's gonna come down
double hard yeah soon and property
a little bit hey hey real talking a
little opportunity to get back in there
son um
i think that you make a great point
i think that they're doing this
sometimes
you make an absolutely great point i
think that seth is being positioned as
the new chrissy teigen
i think that
it's tricky because
when anybody gets robbed you kind of
want empathy instead of figure it out
yeah so maybe it wasn't the right time
to say that [ __ ] it's called living in
the big city it's kind of like annoying
anything bad happens you don't need a
[ __ ] going like this is what it
is yeah
but
he's opening himself up for so much
possible criticism right from a group
that cannot wait for a new figurehead to
criticize yeah yeah they take down
chrissy they need somebody else
chrissy's out of here and seth is
rolling right into it and the problem is
his community is bigging him up like
crazy so he thinks he's doing the right
thing yeah everybody that believes in
the same [ __ ] he believes is going yo
you're the man you thank you for so much
for sharing that you should have shared
it like i think i remember when
remember he was at like some award show
or some [ __ ] remember and he was like
should any of us even be here
he was talking about like social
distancing or something like that
was it the emmys
i don't know he basically called him out
and i'm sure he got tons of positive
feedback from calling him out and if
you're an entertainer you gravitate to
positive feedback you almost can't not
do it it's really crazy that's included
that's 100 yeah we'll go to that [ __ ]
absolutely so it's like if you get
rewarded for something you have to be
incredibly disciplined in the things
that you want to create to not continue
to gravitate towards that i mean this
guy knows how to make movies not only an
actor but he like he actually makes
produces writes films yeah like that's
what he's known for yeah he's not known
for being a [ __ ] twitter celebrity
yeah and he's gonna start being known
for that i know and it's starting to
affect his [ __ ] yeah he put out that
[ __ ] uh santa ink yeah so he put out
a like a claymation movie santa inc with
him and sarah silverman to be fair also
hated uh but it has the lowest ratings
ever on imdb and i think rotten tomatoes
1.1 out of 10 on imdb and a three
percent on rotten tomatoes yeah and then
instead of just being like hey maybe
this thing sucks uh he just blamed white
supremacy on twitter so so he had this
tweet where he was like so it looks like
uh thousands of white supremacists uh
went on imdb and like uh tomato whatever
that thing is around tomatoes and like
uh downvoted our movie blah blah blah
now here's the tricky thing about this
you don't have to call them white
supremacists yep you're calling on white
supremacists because
they disagree with you and it's easier
to label the people you disagree with
you as the worst possible thing you
could come out and say like there are
people that hate me for whatever reason
and they wanted to act in a group to
make this project that we put out look
bad and they wouldn't did that and did
that the second you label them as the
worst possible thing
now you lose the credibility of
an honest reaction to something that
happened yeah every single one of those
people it wasn't someone who's just like
a conservative dude that's kind of
annoying that you're telling people how
to live yeah i also saw the trailer it
doesn't look good but but maybe it's not
what i'm trying to give him the benefit
out for his creative i'm like maybe it's
pretty good and there's a group of
people that hate you but to label every
single one is either a nazi or a white
supremacist like didn't we just learn
this from the trump era like you label
these people as one thing
they're crazy because that should be
working
on his part like for people who use that
strategy
oh so you think he's doing just to
charge up his charges up his people it's
like oh if you don't like this movie you
racist
but don't we hate that ultimatum like
not
barbara that's a bar it's not funny if
you don't like this podcast you're a
racist yeah
oh [ __ ] i see how it works now
[ __ ] we should have been going with that
ever
apparently they think people are upset
that it's a christmas movie made by
people who are like mainly jewish
aren't christians allowed to be upset
with the wally movie and it was a bunch
of [ __ ] christians making it i'd be
like yo that's weird i would agree with
you but every christmas song is made by
a jew
yeah but that's just slamming those go
hearts and this the whole point of this
movie is also also the dumbest [ __ ]
woke [ __ ] ever is why to say like
there's a lineage of santa's and it's
always a white male and then sarah
silverman is this like [ __ ] purple
elf who's like i'm gonna be the new
santa other comments she made that like
you're jew washing you have to be a jew
to play it you like no actors act i'll
sell them play what's wrong is that a
problem if white dudes want to be the
most charitable figure in all of
folklore the guy that goes around and
gives christmas gifts to every kid you
don't want white kids to aspire to be
there no not everything you woke
yourself into a [ __ ] pretzel goofy
[ __ ]
goofy [ __ ] goofy ass [ __ ] and instead
of getting a black girl to be the role
she's like well just make me purple
i'll be a purple elf when she's actual
purple she's like a purple [ __ ]
person yeah she looks like the count
like the same color as the count
was she the armor on that alec baldwin
is that rust was she the girl that
killed everybody on rust is that what
happens was that the first day plus call
back thank you now here's the thing
sarah silverman
seth rogen is it possible that they live
in their own vacuum
yes and because of this they're not even
seeing the criticism
yeah i think they believe i think he
believes it's like [ __ ] anti-semitism
oh do they genuinely believe that i
think he does and also that is an
interesting question like
if you're jewish like
can you make a movie about christmas
then we're all about not culturally
appropriating i mean but also christmas
is like american cultural holiday like
it's religious in its undertones but
like santa's not religious i agree with
your presence it became a cultural thing
and we have a lot of fun and it's not
about jesus it's about santa so yeah
it's about jesus and it's like all right
but also jesus jewish
that's true
that is true but yeah that is true also
in general good luck making a movie
without a couple of jews
this is part of the game yeah 100 so if
you're gonna make a good movie that's
like representative what it is and who
gives a [ __ ] who's doing it